hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
mystery and thriller movie with an
interesting plot called atm
the movie starts by showing a man named
david
who works as a stockbroker one day he is
too tired and says to one of his friends
for he that he wants to go home earlier
corey doesn't allow him because that day
is the last day of their friend emily
working in the office
david secretly likes her in other words
there is no other chance than that day
to get closer with her corey remembers
that tonight there is a christmas party
for all employees
right in the party david sees emily from
a distance he then ventures to approach
her alone their conversation becomes
awkward because he is a person who lacks
confidence
as a result he is left by emily who
wants to go home
after that emily is waiting for a taxi
by the side of the road but david
suddenly approaches her again hoping
they can chat longer their conversation
is so intense so that emily misses her
taxi and has to wait again
david certainly takes the opportunity to
offer her a ride
luckily she accepts the offer
davin then says to corey that he wants
to take emily home first
however corey who has no money takes
advantage of the moment to go home with
david hearing this david is worried that
he would ruin his moment with emily he
tries to give him some money but
unfortunately he doesn't have any either
they finally go home together
in the middle of the trip corey who is
drunk forgets where his cell phone was
he then borrows david's cell phone to
call people at his house saying that he
is on his way home
not long after david's cell phone runs
out of battery corey suddenly feels
hungry and he wants to eat pizza they
finally stop at a local atm booth to
withdraw cash because the pizza outlet
only accepts cash an upset david parks
his car some distance from the booth so
corey has to walk further
shortly after corey calls david from
inside it seems he is having a problem
david rushes inside leaving emily in the
car alone
after a while a curious emily decides to
go inside
it turns out that corey has encountered
card problems
as a result they will use david's money
first
when they want to go back to the car
they spot a hooded figure in a parka
coat lurking outside in the parking lot
the group initially suspect the figure
to be a robber and discover that he
cannot enter the booth without an atm
card later there is a dog walker
approaching him but he immediately kills
the dog walker
seeing the incident they attempt to
phone the police but their only hope is
emily's cell phone which was left in the
car
they panic and look for something to use
meanwhile the hooded man keeps watching
them until 30 minutes later
david is planning to go back to his car
but the strange man seems to notice
something and go straight to david's car
to get a toolbox from the trunk he then
walks towards the back of the room
after some deliberation david didn't go
to his car as they prefer to wait until
morning the hooded man suddenly shuts
down the lights in the booth including
the heater which is meant to keep them
cold
emily unintentionally sees the smoke
detector above them but they don't have
a match to make smoke in the room david
then thinks that the strange man is
asking for money so he decides to
negotiate their safety by giving the
killer 500
emily's earrings and corey's watch the
killer takes the things that has been
given to him david uses the opportunity
to escape to his car where he finds out
that the vehicle's ignition wires have
been severed so the car cannot start he
attempts to call 9-1-1 using emily's
cell phone but eventually he is attacked
by the man
he accidentally drops emily's phone as
he escapes back to the booth the killer
then picks up the phone
they have no clue about what the killer
wants from them
now the only thing that emily has is a
lipstick she desperately uses it to
write help on the booth's window to
attract attention
in the meantime the three of them are
freezing when suddenly a security guard
locates them when the guard sees a dead
body and tries to call the cops
unfortunately the hooded man beats him
to death using a tire iron from david's
car trunk causing the three to be
shocked
soon a man with a similar coat enters
the booth he is immediately killed by
david and corey when they check his
identity card it is revealed to be only
an innocent janitor who cleans the booth
every morning corey decides to use the
coat from the janitor
feeling frustrated he chooses to leave
from the booth but sadly he gets caught
by the trap and stabbed by the hooded
man
the killer starts to walk towards the
back and brings a water hose
after several hours david and emily
accidentally realize that corey is still
alive
they retrieve him from outside narrowly
managing to return to the booth before
the hooded man can get to them
after that the man blocks the booth door
with david's car and tries to freeze
them to death by filling the booth with
cold water as the result corey dies of
blood loss and hypothermia insanely the
killer puts a chair just to watch their
action from the outside
later david manages to find a lighter
from the janitor's coat he then lifts
emily on his shoulders to trigger the
fire sprinkler system alarm but sadly he
slips causing emily to fall and fatally
break her neck
the hooded man slams david's car into
the booth
angered david improvises a molotov
cocktail from corey's alcohol bottle and
throws it at the killer but the figure
he sets ablaze turns out to be the dead
guard at the end the police arrive to
arrest david as the hooded man hides
himself in the crowd in other words he
is suspected of breaking into an atm and
premeditated murder because he is the
only person in that place
he tries to explain everything to the
police but he still gets ignored as he
is driven away he sees many figures
wearing parkas in the crowd the police
recover surveillance recordings of the
events in the atm booth but it is made
clear that the killer had planned his
actions so as not to appear in the
footage miraculously framing david for
his crimes the movie ends with the
hooded man returns to his headquarters
and then he immediately sits down at his
desk and begins to plan similar attacks
on the other atms subscribe to watch
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching